yeah welcome to this video okay I don't
know you don't really know how to do it
but I need to end this kind of
frustrated you playing really really
badly slowish overlooking stuff and not
really exploiting things okay so i hope
that this is going to be better got a
french defence and i'm trying to play
quick on not losing much time okay so we
actually allowed this kind of activation
here with bishop only for you should be
six was a threat i had to attend to that
jaw how do you play this no idea
actually i can put this bishop i would
but probably I mean have to probably
cancel long anyway hard to imagine out
without it yeah now he has covered the C
2 square but I don't know how how
important that is let's just make sure
that it's nots not that much happening
here then go go about things here I
cannot take a three year I can oops i
can trade stuff here just try to be a
bit quicker I mean maybe it's not the
one hundred percent best move but I'd
fail to fight those anyway at the moment
so better better try to be be quick
about it hmm okay I don't know maybe
putting it on the long diagonal isn't
even helping much what can I do here the
special p is nice just arrest them a
little bit I I need a plan okay I'm
taking this it's maybe Queenie for and I
don't Quinn trade would be okay i think
i have this player on the on the b pawn
rook c8 rooks is 6 and so on takes a
while maybe he's quicker on the King
side but ok I'm just going to block it
completely by putting the piece there is
maybe going with this yep possible yeah
okay maybe this was most kind of kind of
bad putting the Queen down he's ready to
play be three maybe
Jeff Luc a six it's not helping much
probably still night over to see four
would be good to cover cover b7 first
then night c forum at least I was pretty
quick what is basically inviting this
move surprising so why can I not take a
three I don't see it should takes rook
chinks and just taking it come on
now it's really just a pawn I will try
to somehow muddy the waters but that
should be it should be doable and need
to trade queens that would be would be
helpful maybe here for group c 6 b 6 p-6
yeah
so just queen bee too and yeah I guess
so Queen trade should win with the a
porn and I don't really see how we avoid
that I mean 23 I'm just invading Quincy
one and yeah so Quincy one and then 92
maybe 22 was also trading queens right
let's do that pin also having 94 in mind
okay we'll march as pawns up so what am
i doing I have to be careful in one way
that I don't then I don't allow the
bishop to come over to eight or
something but don't think this is a big
problem five and now let's let's push
push pause here just a moment was b5
easier a 3 Bishop b3
hmm that's probably easier and what now
putting putting the knight on e4 s
current time morning I know then it can
actually take a fork we need for for
King III
we should be 593 and then the apron is
running and then the bishop actually
doesn't leave never Square to cover that
has to go to f3 or something now okay
then it's even then it's even easier
yeah we got a winning Wow 90 is letting
the clock run down nope okay but I'm
really promoting now right it's no way
to stop the porn check
check yeah I will get another Queen just
no stalemate please check check check
mate okay so let's let's have a look at
this game oh this is very closed version
of them advanced french where black is
activating is Bishop did with this
Bishop to a form nouveau and white is
playing on the Kings side I don't really
know I mean it looks it looks okay for
black I think having this pieces on the
queenside but he has some play of course
with f4 and so on yeah I just wanted to
hold things for a while there and then
go ahead on the queenside I don't know
this is probably not very precise it's
not like bad but it's not doing much so
here malicious was a bit silly and now
interesting i just took this and it just
may be debatable the night wasn't
threatening to go anywhere I was
thinking that I could play I play the
night away and work to be 6 and so on
but and he got he got this Bishop 21
queen bee three was a bit a bit silly
Angus and he got in b3 which is this is
not not so clear actually it opens up
the be far for his rock but also leaves
weaknesses behind it might be just okay
for me right what is the computer saying
up like it's better maybe b3 was really
questionable I wasn't I wasn't
completely sure about it it's um no here
i can take c three actually
yeah I was so focused on reaching this
night that I didn't pay any attention
again 94 is good but this is winning the
a three-prong so it cannot be bad ready
yeah you want to want to trade those
irritating pieces and oh I missed the
movie a queen a4 is a draw wow that
would have been very disappointing hmm
yeah if I do this you can take care and
he has this kind of draw Quincy 85 well
okay so Queen B 2 was a bad move i have
to do i mean basically whatever and not
that Queen B 5 is a suggestion of the
engine then March the apron with the
wind wow ok and here i can also just
push the april i would have been good as
well right here it really should be a
winner I kind of struggled for a moment
but I here exactly i could have pushed
because i am he's running into into a
fork check yeah my plan was to go here
but that's not not really helping
anymore King bee three so back and just
start a new it is it is a winner I mean
I played it not in the best way but it's
enough ok thanks for watching